I did a a video I don't know it was the
last month or so and I mentioned
passport Bros in passing and I think for
the most part have you ever heard that
term before by the way
yes yeah absolutely and actually if you
could give me like the quickest
definition I think it's kind of like a
red pill thing where you kind of escape
to a place where women treat you better
or money goes further are those the two
elements that seems to be the underlying
notion is that Western women aren't the
greatest uh they don't treat you very
well Western culture tax rates all that
sort of stuff are kind of abusive so
um I think a lot of guys that don't do
well in the west tend to uh relocate to
greener pastures you know if that makes
sense that they think that they'll end
up doing better somewhere in Latin
America Eastern Europe Asia you know for
example
um did you go anywhere else when you
were sort of moving around and trying to
settle somewhere did you try out Latin
America did you try Eastern Europe
before you went yeah well I traveled all
over the world
um I didn't Eastern Europe I didn't try
I guess I just I went to England and
Italy so a little bit of Europe but
those aren't places to go for women
those are terrible places to go for for
women you might as well be in America
but so I didn't try these like Russian
Ukrainian countries I've heard such good
things about or Poland or something and
but I did try South I did check out
South America and different Asian
countries and after traveling all around
Thailand was the best for me but I had
some backup plan ideas okay cool
um yeah so I I figured that you'd be a
great guy to have this conversation with
because every time I mention anything
around passport Bros I'll always get DMS
and emails from people like I'm the real
passport bro you need to interview me
and I'll click a link and it goes to
like some YouTube channel where they're
like telling guys how to be passport
rows but they're mostly dorks
um so I think this isn't your main scope
of understanding but it's a big part of
your life and why you're in Thailand
Beyond you know easy access to Peds and
better weather and nice beaches and all
that cool stuff
um so you settled on Asia uh why
Thailand out of Asia like what what
brought you there
well now I would choose Thailand for one
reason because weed is legal here which
it isn't in any of the other Asian
countries but even before it was
legalized I still chose Thailand because
it had I'd say more freedom and your
money goes further
and the way the women treat you I mean
but the thing is you can get the the way
the women treat you in Philippines is is
perhaps even better uh so if it was just
for women I would have probably chosen
Philippines yeah yeah for women I would
choose Philippines so I that's where
that beats Thailand
um but Philippines doesn't have the
infrastructure the technology the access
to high quality consumer goods
so if I want to keep working or being
productive and I want fast internet and
I want good technology
uh and and in Thailand everything is
just so convenient like I I've been some
countries where you know you've got to
find a pharmacy and good luck you're
gonna spend half a day looking for the
right Pharmacy or you want good food
just gonna spend an hour looking for
good food and in Thailand it's like you
walk down the street and you've got
Pharmacy good food short time Hotel
massage girls to meet uh interesting
foreigners from all over the world so
it's got pretty much everything that you
could want in Thailand you know how long
have you been there now
three and a half years okay cool yeah
because I remember some of the earlier
videos over the last couple years and I
don't think you have those up on a
channel anymore you lost those channels
a lot of channels got deleted yeah okay
have been censored so many times you
know deep platform whatever Donald Trump
the same thing happened to Donald Trump
Andrew Tate all that started happening
to me you know six years ago okay yeah
it's weird because some people were
highly targeted on YouTube and others
they just sort of didn't really bother I
mean I I'm not sure if I sort of slipped
under the radar just because I don't
really dive into certain Topics in a
certain way or I I use certain languages
like
that avoids problems you know sort of
stuff what do you think it has a lot to
do with how much you sensationalize it
so you are speaking very intelligently
and and calm and you're not like
flashing crazy things on the screen the
issue that the the government and the
entities that sought to censor me uh had
was that I was I was flashing the cars
like the you know exotic cars and and
bodybuilder body and lifestyle and girls
and then a lot of young men were
following me and these enemies of
Freedom felt that I was a a big enough
threat to influence them based on the
imagery not just what I was saying what
I was saying plus the imagery so
that's what happens with Andrew Tate
also why he's censored is because he's
showing he in the enemies of Freedom's
mind they're saying this is a danger
because this is someone who could really
go viral and like influence young minds
and and lead them in a direction that is
not beneficial to The Matrix yeah big um
you know big strong men that have uh you
know abundance of choices with women are
a big threat now aren't they yeah yeah
isn't that interesting uh you know that
used to be celebrated decades ago uh if
you're a Playboy then
um you know they they sort of held you
up on a pedestal today it's now you
still kind of get some level of respect
out of it but at the same time they're
um they don't want a strong masculine
independent uh free-thinking culture do
they yeah the government doesn't want
that the large corporations don't want
that and the public you know these these
non-player characters
um that instead of improving their own
life they they try to decrease the
quality of other people's lives to make
theirs better like the men that are like
that they don't want to feel jealous
seeing another man be successful at
these things and then the women don't
want it because it makes them feel like
they're lower value and that they have
less power so that's what the battle in
the west is about is is like women
taking advantage of this moment and
simping men taking advantage of this to
like build up women into something that
they're not like a complete illusion
so um how is Thai politics and Thai
culture different than like Western
countries
um before you answer that though so I
don't forget uh Tony's newest YouTube
channel is linked in the title of this
video so if you guys want to go uh check
out his new stuff subscribe to his
channel but go ahead
so cultural differences in in political
differences well the politics in
Thailand is that you have a a king but
we'll say like a royal family that owns
everything it's one of the most powerful
families in the world people don't
realize how powerful the family is and
they own and control pretty much
everything they make money off of
everything and if if it doesn't doesn't
benefit them then it doesn't really
happen if it does benefit them then it
gets really expedited so it's kind of
weird like a family owns the country or
the and not just a family but the
family's friends and it trickles down
like the closer you are related to the
royal family the more you uh
get you know Royal Treatment
um and then you also then you have like
the the very lower Society that's kind
of uh uh
groomed to be the servant class
um so you have which is the case in all
of these countries that there's a huge
disparity between of wealth between the
wealthy and the and the working class so
you you have like this huge working
class that makes very low wages and the
wonderful thing about that is you can
actually hire services like massage
get your nails done you know labor for
very very cheap
um so that that's that's uh and that
that there's a lot of like economic
benefits to that to the country too and
in America you know it's like like
hiring a nanny for example is just it's
just crazy expensive but hiring a nanny
and raising children in Thailand is is
super cheap and I'm in the child raising
phase of my life also so like that's a
huge savings to have my children grow up
here
um
so that's the politics
um the the laws are you know the laws
are kind of similar around the world I
guess one of the big differences is
um you know you're guilty until proven
of an innocent or innocent until proven
guilty type thing but even in America
now it used to be supposedly innocent
until proven guilty but now the way that
the media works with the law enforcement
and they do press releases and you're
pretty much guilty and your life's
destroyed as soon as the government
decides so so it's really in the end not
that different we don't have that much
Freedom if the government doesn't like
you they can destroy you here they can
destroy you in America in America you
have the freedom of speech sort of
because you get censored so much in
Thailand you don't really have a freedom
of speech you're not supposed to
publicly say bad things about people in
general like defamation is a quasi-crime
and uh you certainly can't say anything
negative about the royal family
um and and I I think that the politics
of Thailand worked extremely well for
Thailand in the past if you have a
benevolent dictator that's probably the
best government that you could have and
so yes of course like government's
number one priority in any country is to
protect the wealth of their friends
that's above all else
um so that's that's inherent in every
government
um but you know when the leader
the previous leader was very loving to
the people and wanted to really help the
people you know he brought a lot of
Tourism he allowed a lot of freedom he
built the infrastructure here that other
countries in Asia didn't have uh so it
was a really I think 10 15 years ago
especially Thailand was probably the
best place on the planet like no
question in my by my standards uh but
now you know the quality of life in
Thailand has dropped a lot some say it's
increased because it's got better access
to consumer goods and Technology but
from what the potential it could be
based on those technological advances it
should be better but unfortunately you
know Thailand just like most countries
are kind of bowing to this globalist
um surveillance Nanny state so that that
is happening but it's just way slower
like China's North Korea are leading
that America is you know gonna try to
follow and then these other countries
are step behind I really really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out